[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
Knorr I prefer to think of it dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where me
Hank green and John Green that other guy
answer your questions and give you
devious advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and of course
AFC Wimbledon John how you doing I'm
doing terribly thank you for asking I
broke my rib almost a week ago it is
extremely painful everything hurts it
hurts to stand it hurts to sit it hurts
to lie down I can't sleep at night it
just sucks I don't even really want to
talk about it
but I also can't think about anything
else so just tell me how you're doing
I'm doing good I'm doing good you know
pain John is a sign that you're not dead
so there's that going for you I find
that to be extraordinarily cold comfort
I think that pain is the stupidest of
all the human experiences it is the one
that I have found the least meaningful
but I am admittedly a little bit biased
right now Hank uh we need to get to an
important topic
INRI last week's podcast which is that
oh is it isn't the spelling and
pronunciation of view it is the spelling
and pronunciation of huge we have never
experienced quite the deluge of emails
tweets etcetera INRI the spelling of
huge what I found most fascinating this
is the how to shorten the word usual
what I found most fascinating is how
many people were completely convinced
that they knew the correct spelling of
yuge and that all the other Spelling's
were stupid yeah specifically the ones
who were clearly wrong and yet
everybody's spelling disagreed with
everyone else's except yeah for the one
person who was an actual linguist oh
yeah we had several I I felt as if we
had several linguists common thing on
the matter and indeed cringing at at our
at our our armchair linguist miss what
are you late ling linguist adiy what is
what is the linguist version of
philosophy I believe it's an Inquisitor
I believe that's correct
armchair linguistics I did it I remember
so somebody wrote in with a link to an
extensive linguist conversation on this
topic and I just want to read a little
bit of it we'll link to it on our
patreon patreon comm slash dear Hank and
John
the reason this problem arises is that
the consonant in the middle of usual
which fo Natisha n--'s call the voiced
palliative v leo are fricative and which
is written in the international phonetic
alphabet as this thing that isn't a
letter doesn't have a fixed
representation in the english writing
system anyway the long and short of it
is that most of the linguists I heard
from think that it should be u z h or u
zhe yuge
yeah i guess i'd probably pronounce that
use u zhe but I will say that Hank on
this website there are lots of linguists
proper linguists fighting this out about
how to best represent huge in Latin
letters so we are not alone in feeling
you know kind of lost in this
conversation I also have to say that
Katherine I walked I got an home from
work I walked into my house and I hear
my own voice and yours come in from
upstairs and Katherine is listening to
this section of the podcast and she's
sitting on the couch in on her lap as
her laptop and she's she's looking at
urban dictionary to see what the most
common Spelling's on urban dictionary
for you are and indeed there are a
number of different different spellings
of views on urban urban dictionary you
zhe is one of them but the most common
one is the one that I suggested which
was just you je and and so that that was
that seemed to be in terms of the
colloquial not not necessarily the phone
at his heads and/or the linguists the
correct spelling but the colloquial
spelling might just be you je and I will
say that was my call yeah I'm gonna just
stop you right there and point out that
when you're trying to use urban
dictionary to back up your arguments
you're in trouble already
one more correction in the form of a
short poem Hank before we start the
proper podcast
a couple weeks ago you talked about the
Martian Rover singing itself happy
birthday alone on Mars and I've written
a short poem in response six light
minutes from Earth alone on a red planet
which incidentally is not a shade of
brown
a Martian Rover does not sing itself
happy birthday how is this my this is
the correction that we received from
this is the correction Hank the Martian
Rovers saying itself happy birthday once
on its first birthday since then it has
not sung itself happy birthday this is
an urban legend that you have propagated
my bad this is a correction sent to us
by Michelle who has a friend who works
on the Curiosity rover and also linked
to us to an actual article that from
from the Curia a tweet from the
Curiosity rover confirming that it does
not do this every year but only on the
first year John do you want to do any
questions yeah sure let's get to some
questions from our listeners this first
one is from Charlene who writes dear
John and Hank my husband and I were
discussing what we would do with lottery
winnings of multiple billions of dollars
I said that amount of money was too much
for a single person to hold on to and
that I would give away the majority of
it my husband said he would never want
to give any of it away
I mean Charlene any of it really I'm
concerned that your husband might be a
terrible person anyway I asked
incredulously what he would do with all
that money and he said he always wanted
to swim in a vault of money like Scrooge
McDuck I want to know what denominations
of money would be best for swimming and
how big of a room would you need to
store it the denominations of money so
that it equalled just one of the
billions he wants to keep swimming in ah
Hank I thought this was an interesting
question because I if I were to win a
billion dollars or get a billion dollars
however in whatever way I have to tell
you I would give almost all of it away
immediately
just because just because you don't want
to have that that hanging over you and
have everyone know that about you that I
don't think that it's good for your kids
really to inherit huge sums of money I
think that it can be very distorting in
their lives and not will not allow them
to have their own
it lives that are independent of their
parents I feel like it would be a weird
amount of pressure
mm-hm and I just I don't feel like it
would in any way make my life better now
like there are lots of sums of money
that would make my life better but I
don't think a billion dollars is one of
them well in that case like you might as
well just build a vault up with it and
and I have but I have to say that if you
fill a vault with coins and you jump
into it from a diving board that is you
know any more than a few feet above the
surface of the coins you're gonna die
like you gotta hit that yeah you're
about to duck your neck like the coins
do not make a liquid scrooge mcduck had
special superpowers that that allowed
him to swim in money and indeed I
remember an episode of the duck tails
where Scrooge was swimming around and
the the boys he we doing Louie jumped in
and were unable to and were were
unpleasantly surprised by how they had
run into a solid wall of metal so you
would have to mix together I think some
like have some kind of system to mix
together paper currency as well as maybe
a little bit of coinage to give density
but you would have to have a system to
constantly mix it because they would
fall out or you could create maybe some
kind of origami shape where you were
putting some currency inside of a bill
and then folding the bill up in a
certain way that would create a density
more suitable to swimming around in I
think that it's not impossible to figure
out a way to make this work but it is
it's not simple either ya know here's
what I would say Hank I would say that
Charlene's husband is genuinely risking
death by inheriting a billion dollars or
winning a billion dollars and turning it
into a pool full of coins which i think
is pretty metaphorically resonant INRI
what it would be actually like to
suddenly have a billion dollars yes I I
would take a billion dollars though
because I'd have a lot of fun giving it
away we've got another question
it's from Katherine who asks dear Hank
and John I was in my backyard
spray-painting and I accidentally
spray-painted a part of a bush blue
while making some lovely squid art I
tried spray-painting the bush green but
the shades of green
don't match what do I do Hank I don't
know if we're gonna have the same
response to this one but you want to
just say on three what we think
Katherine should do yes one two three
move burn your entire house down yeah
okay so if we're in the same direction
here like this is a crisis and the only
way to deal with it is to run screaming
from this property like this this should
not be your house anymore you're never
gonna be able to get that Bush back the
correct shade of green you need to just
probably move to a whole different city
yeah I mean I'd go to Mars if you could
well you can't fortunately but I don't
think you need to go to Mars I but I
think you need to like you need to
reinvent your whole life you need it
just you and that one work of squid art
need to walk out that door with no other
belongings and just find a new life for
yourself in fact Katherine don't even
named yourself Katherine in this new
life like you can have no connection to
the person that spray-painted that Bush
blue like you've got to be a completely
different person except you'll always
know that you're still you when you look
up and you see that squid art all right
well I think we've covered that one
pretty well John do you have any other
questions for us no that was it that was
the end that's the end of the podcast
all right I got one though if you want
me to keep going
it's from Parker who asks dear Hank and
John what the heck even is accounting I
know it's important and there are a lot
of really smart people who are great at
it but it is just not click in my brain
why do I have to take accounting for my
management major can't I just check a
box that says I will hire an accountant
can't I just take an accounting
vocabulary class so I understand what my
accountant is talking about
best wishes Park Wow it hurts to laugh
but the idea that you could check
apothem that's just the problem with the
checking the box Parker is that if you
check a box saying I will hire an
accountant you're essentially checking a
box that says I'm going to give someone
free reign to steal from me because I
will have no idea whether they are
telling me the truth
there's that and in general as
a businessperson it is always good to
understand what all of the people in
your organization are doing even if you
aren't doing it as far as the question
what the heck even is accounting I think
you could Google that one but you know
it's keeping account of what all the
money is doing that's why they call it
accounting yeah I mean it turns out to
be really important to know whether your
business is losing money or making money
and like for a long time in Hank and i's
career we did not pay attention to that
question and it turns out like to be a
deeply interesting and important
question and we sort of missed the boat
by not giving it a little more attention
early on maybe also I think that I
enjoyed the way that we did it but I you
know there there is there are managers
who don't know how to do accounting and
and and I certainly am NOT an accountant
or anything but like I think that you're
in school to learn stuff and you should
you should learn stuff even if you don't
like learning it is that okay to say
yeah also it's helpful in your I would
argue it's helpful in your everyday life
like for many many years I did not know
how to read an Excel spreadsheet I did
not know how to balance my checkbook and
that stuff was really stressful for me
it caused me a lot of stress and anxiety
and it turns out that like in the end it
isn't that hard I just had to do the
work to learn how to be able to do those
things and once I could I suddenly felt
like I had you know a little bit of
control over my financial life instead
of it being something that was happening
to me you know my bank occasionally
writing to say that I had overdrawn my
account and then I'm not like thrown
into a panic like I was I was instead in
a situation where I felt like okay I'm
in I have some control over this I know
why this happened I know why that
happened and it's really empowering for
me so I actually I I think it's worth it
to learn some basic accounting no matter
what you're gonna do it yeah I mean I'm
sure that Parker's accounting class is
more advanced than that and that is why
he's finding it particularly annoying
but
but those yeah I it's it's valuable I'm
gonna just say it's valuable and that's
gonna be and in general i I feel like if
you're enjoying more than 50% of your
work then you're good and so maybe this
is just part of the 50% that you don't
love what uh what percentage of your
work do you enjoy do you think I
probably enjoy 80 80 to 90% of my work
that's interesting I think I think I'm
in a similar I think I'm probably like
75% but I feel really good about that
like I didn't there hasn't been a time
in my life when I've enjoyed as high a
percentage of my work as I do right now
yeah I mean it's it's interesting
because there's a difference between
what I enjoy doing and what I enjoy
thinking about doing and what I dread so
like there are things that I dread that
I enjoy doing I don't I don't know if
that sounds insane but like like I'm
like I have to do that thing and then
once I'm doing it I'm like this is fine
and great and I actually quite like it
but before I'm doing it I'm I spend a
lot of time being stressed out about the
fact that I have to do it the big
distinction in my life is there are some
things I enjoyed doing and there are
some things I enjoy having done so I
definitely enjoy having written much
more than I enjoy writing but that said
like I do I like writing enough to
consider it in the 75% of stuff that I
like doing the 25% of stuff is mostly
paperwork and emails yeah yeah it's
mostly it's a lot of email for me it's
also like just when things go wrong you
know it's like that's the stuff and I
feel like that percentage that increased
dramatically it's like if it's a month
where things are going wrong more but
that always makes stuff much harder when
it's not going well and we're very I've
been very lucky to have things go very
well you know for the most part yeah
things are going pretty well these days
Hank fail failure is unpleasant as much
as I try to say that it is just a part
of process and of course everybody fails
and this is part of it's the thing that
is going to be a part of your life but
it is unpleasant and I don't like it it
is unpleasant but man
you learn a lot more from failure than
you learn from success in my experience
definitely true
the problem with success is that it
tells you that like you know things are
always going to be easy and you're a
special snowflake and there's nobody
like you and that's why you're gonna
always succeed everywhere you go and
then failure teaches you a lot yep
all right this question is from Hannah
Hank who writes Dear John and Hank I'm
kind of very confused about how gas
planets work are they just like a really
big clouds how do they maintain a
uniform shape how do they have an orbit
do they have a surface or gravity how
dense are they okay actually ignore all
those questions and just answer this one
if an airplane can fly through a cloud
could a rocket ship hypothetically fly
through Jupiter they don't teach these
things in my public school Hannah that's
a fantastic questions that I've never
even paused to consider well first of
all I'll say that if a if a airplane is
going fast enough it actually can't fly
through air there comes a point at which
air is dense enough gas is dense enough
that it will tear the plane apart you
see this as meteors are coming through
our atmosphere at a very high speed they
get very hot because the gases in front
of them are being compressed and all
that energy is being turned into heat
they break apart they're ripped into
pieces and they explode and that is one
of the crazy things about about gases
they seem like they're hardly there at
all but if you're moving fast enough
they're basically a brick wall just like
Scrooge McDuck scoyne x' so a rocket
ship could you know fly into Jupiter if
it was going slow enough it was going
the speed that a rocket ship normally
goes it would totally be ripped apart by
the gas but the way that it works is
it's basically all like gas has mass
it's the gaseous matter and it has a
mass and it has a weight and so it
creates gravity and all of that gas
altogether pulls itself together into
this giant thing and at the very middle
it's very dense because there's so much
gas that there's all this pressure being
pushed down on
by gravity and down there at the in the
center of Jupiter we do not know what is
there we don't know if they're like
probably what's there is it's like like
it's under so much pressure that the gas
becomes metallic it like it it goes from
being a gas to being a solid or a liquid
and you've got this like metallic
hydrogen core of Jupiter we're not sure
though because it is a giant planet and
we will never be able to go into the
middle of it because whatever we would
send down there would totally get
crushed by that tremendous pressure so
it's just a it's a collection of gas in
a in a sphere that is being held
together in a sphere just like a liquid
would or just like a solid would our
planet being solid has been crushed into
this spherical a spherical shape by the
gravity by the density of its own mass
and that's also what's happened in with
Jupiter I find something about that just
astonishingly beautiful the idea that
we'll never know what the center of
Jupiter looks like and we have to like
live in a universe knowing that that's
something that we can never know well
John we don't even know what the like
the the center of Earth looks like we
have some ideas but those ideas continue
progressing and changing and yeah we now
I don't like to correct you on science
stuff but I am gonna have to just ask
you to hit the pause button on that one
because in fact I don't know if you've
read Journey to the Center of the Earth
but Jules Verne has explored that in
really like exciting details so if you
haven't read that book I truly recommend
it because it tells you exactly what the
center of the earth is like and it's
awesome do you want to do another
another science question John sure yeah
no the less I have to talk the better
all right this one's from Andrew who
asks dear Hank and John according to a
scishow video that I saw recently salted
the ocean is just a mix of minerals
picked up over thousands of years and
not sodium chloride like table salt so
what is the sea salt they put on my
Wendy's fries is that less healthy than
table salt actually I don't know if we
misspoke in that scishow episode or if
you misheard but it is a mix of minerals
the primary one being sodium chloride so
the the sea salt that they put on your
fries at Wendy's is mostly sodium
chloride but
salt also has a bunch of other stuff in
it like magnesium chloride and just
whatever other salts which is what we
call these ionic compounds in chemistry
whatever other salts got picked up as
rivers flow down to the sea and so that
that table salt is mostly salt well the
table salt is also dium chloride sea
salt is mostly sodium chloride with some
other stuff thrown in and that other
stuff might be beneficial you probably
get in other ways though in addition to
it getting it in sea salt which is why
sea salt is mostly let's be honest it's
just salt yeah I very rarely hear of
people who aren't getting enough salt
here in at least in the United States we
don't have a huge sodium shortage no
it's it's the other stuff that's in the
sea salt that they think maybe you
should be getting like like magnesium or
phosphorous or whatever but like do you
get that stuff other I will say on the
topic of salts as you know Hank I am a
committed bather I do not believe in
showers which are essentially just
getting attacked by millions of pellets
of water or very kind of sort of
liquefied bullets shooting you millions
at a time and so I take bands and I
enjoy nothing more than bath salts when
I am bathing what what a pleasure is
that is that the whole story is that
just the thing you wanted to tell me
yeah what are what our bath salts well
as far as I can tell they're smelly
salts but I I there is a drug called
bath salts like a recreational drug I
know about yes because I was a the TSA
took my bath salts from my carry-on bag
once when I was trying to get on an
airplane and they were like what is this
and I was like that's mother's and my
bath salts I'm a I'm a committed baby I
know I'm gonna be out of town for two
days and I looked up the hotel room that
I'm gonna be in and I got a picture of
its bathtub and everything looks like
it's going to be a great bathtub I'm
very excited and they were like what why
are you taking bath salts to New York
City and I was like because I because I
like to bathe in hotel rooms and III use
bath salts doesn't everyone who takes
baths and anyway it was a big
miscommunication because apparently
bath salts are also a drug but I have I
genuinely don't know if the bath salts
that are the recreational drug are also
the bath salts that you buy at Bed Bath
and Beyond but if they are I might
accidentally be addicted to bad cells
well I think you might be addicted to
bath salts but only the kind that go in
your bath which are definitely different
from the kind that people use as
recreational drugs though I imagine they
look somewhat similar which is why they
got that name but yeah not to say I mean
I I wouldn't say that my use of bath
salts rises to the level of a
recreational drug but I will say that I
really like it it's probably especially
helpful and to soothe that aching pain
of having having a ribbon in several
pieces it's just so the kind of rib
fracture I have is it's not what's
called a simple rib fracture it's called
a displaced rib fracture which means the
two parts of my rib don't line up
perfectly oh but they're always trying
to get back together and so when I move
they're like moving against each other
and it hurts so freakin bad that sounds
awful and and what I know about because
I recently separated some cartilage from
a rib which is a very different but
still painful thing and that the doctor
was like yeah there's not really
anything you can do it's the rib just uh
don't hurt it yeah my doctor was great
in the ER she was like you're so lucky
you didn't lacerate your liver and I was
like I don't feel lucky like that's a
very specific definition of luck like if
do you wake up every morning doctor and
say I won the lottery today didn't
lacerate my liver yeah I would argue
that I was incredibly unlucky yeah
well you know there's always somebody
who has it worse my doctor when I first
was diagnosed was altered ulcerative
colitis was like if you're gonna be
diagnosed with ulcerative colitis this
is the kind you want and I was like well
I don't know that's something that's
something to know no I don't I'm not a
big fan of that if that beds that
particular bedside manner
of like you won't believe your good
fortune here's all the things that
aren't wrong with you it works for some
people not for others it works okay for
me all right let's move on to another
question this question is from Natalie
who writes Dear John and Hank I'm a
first-time email or a new listener after
my hairstylist recommended your podcast
first off I just want to thank America's
hair stylists for being such consistent
supporters of the pod secondly I will
now read the rest of the question the
question that has been the bane of my
existence for quite some time
is what is proper door etiquette how
long do I hold the door open for someone
when you open the door and someone is
standing on the other side also looking
at you with the deer and headlights
expression who goes first I really don't
understand these these are great
questions they're two it's two distinct
questions Hank there's the first when
when you open the door and you look
behind you and someone is coming but
they are in that middle distance where
they are not about to be there but they
also aren't like far away do you hold
the door open and for how long and then
the second question when you open a door
and you see that there is someone about
to come out of the door as you are about
to go in it who goes first
John I was at a very weird situation so
in Montana of course we have double
doors like there's like a vestibule to
keep the hot air inside in the winter I
was a very weird situation where I was
walking up to the bagel place someone
opened the door to go into the bagel
place then I was coming in behind them
and they were kind of holding the door
for me though they weren't sure if I was
going into the bagel place so if I was
just walking sort of abnormally close to
the building headed somewhere else and
and then inside so they were looking at
me but inside there was a person who had
opened the other vestibule door and was
holding the door open for the person who
was holding the door may be opened for
me but maybe not and everybody and then
like like and suddenly everybody got
very confused and they all just like
scattered and and people like dropped
doors started running it was it was very
straight and I don't know that there was
any way to do it except for the way that
we ended up doing it which was just
every man for himself the rules have
broken and we just have to deal with the
situation
as it comes to us it was basically the
purge you know like like there were
there no dialling purge now it's just
it's just people on their own as animals
just trying to get through the day yeah
and I was just like well and now like
now but also the problem that I hate
this when you hold the door open for
someone and then they go in in front of
you but then they're in front of you in
line and you're like hey I like I wanted
to hold the door for you but I wasn't
giving you my spot in line I hate that
so you've got to walk in you know I
disagree with you on that one I think if
you hold the door open for someone that
is a statement I I am now putting myself
in a position where you shall be ahead
of me in all the future interactions
that we have the thing I don't like is
the double door situation where you hold
the door open for someone in the double
door situation and then they of course
are the first to the next door and then
they hold the door open for you and you
end up winning by by trying to be
generous you end up being in first place
I love that I think that that's the
wonderful thing about about the double
door is that like I can hold the door
open for you but then I still get my
proper spot and let's see for me like I
believe the last shall be first not the
last shall be first and then last again
so I think that's just a worldview
difference but I so I'm gonna argue that
in general this this door thing both
these door problems
boil down to the need to be kind and
generous toward each other and also
careful of each other like ultimately
what it boils down to is that if you
feel like somebody didn't hold the door
open for you and you were close enough
that they should have held the door open
for you
you need to pause and say to yourself
you know what that person probably had a
brief moment of crisis and made the best
decision that they could make in that
moment they're not a bad person they're
not out to get me they just they made
the call that they thought was right in
that moment and I don't think it was
right but I'm gonna be okay with it
alternately if you are the person
holding open the door and you look and
you're like I think that person is a
little too far away just make the best
call that you can make in that moment
and assume
that everybody is gonna be ok with it
and not gonna be mad at you you know
what I do John I kind of I if I sort of
look a little bit before I open the door
to see if maybe there's anybody around
in a way that makes it clear that like
when I open the door and I feel like
that person's too far away I don't have
to look back at them and acknowledge
their existence before closing the door
in front of them I can I I sort of like
know that they're back there and I don't
look at all and I just let it go as if
I'm just an unthinking person rather
than someone who is intentionally
closing a door on someone it's not
trying to surreptitiously look you know
don't do sometimes if I feel like
somebody's a little too far away all
just sort of as I'm opening the door
I'll look back at them and I'll just
sort of shrug as if to say like sorry
man but like I don't know how to hold
this door open I honestly will sometimes
slow down as I'm approaching the door if
I know that so there's someone who's a
bit farther away so that like just like
take a real long time open in that door
like oh I got destroyed by this
newspaper stand
and now I'm looking at that for a little
while to make like let the person catch
up so that I but I will say John so
here's a thing that I do that I wouldn't
mind if other people did but I'm not
saying it's a necessary part of being a
polite human when I have the door opened
for me and it's a restaurant or
something where there's a line I will
then stand by the door and let the
person go in front of me so that they
like so that they are not punished for
being kind and opening a door for me
yeah I mean I there's a lot of a lot of
etiquette that goes I think in general
in human life almost all the time unless
you are in a true like Wendy's emergency
where if you don't get your Wendy's as
soon as possible you're gonna faint
like if you're in on the edge of a
diabetic coma or something I think it's
almost always the right thing to do to
just say to the person who you held the
door open for why don't you go first
I am a big believer in like those little
tiny acts of kindness making life
bearable like I try this is hard to do
but
if you can imagine in the 99% of time
when you aren't in a tremendous hurry
and like when there isn't huge pressure
on you to get something done if you can
remember that and remember that like you
are not actually in a rush and you can
treat other people as if they are in a
rush their days get so much better like
they go home and they talk about this
person who was nice to them
because that I really believe like it's
made that much of a difference in my
life in those times when I've been in a
huge rush and people have been kind to
me like it it makes a lasting difference
like we talked in a recent episode
remember where the I was jogging and the
I said good morning and the person said
it's 1202
yeah that made a lasting difference in
my life like that stranger had a lasting
impact in my life it's just kind of a
negative impact I think you don't like
try to find those little moments to have
that positive impact it's huge no I
completely agree and I also really
enjoyed doing it like I feel like
increasing the amount of appreciation in
the world is it makes me feel better as
well yeah so you win you win when you
hold the door open for someone and let
them go in line first which reminds me
Hank that today's podcast is brought to
you by Wendy's Wendy's you don't have to
get there first
to get those delicious C salted fries
that's absolutely true it's absolutely
true today's podcast is also brought to
you by accounting it's uh it's necessary
if you want to run a business and
there's parts of your job that you're
not gonna like and it might be one of
them accounting laughing hurts so much
and today's podcast is also brought to
you by bath salts bath salts the kind
that you put in the bath and finally
this podcast is brought to you by
Charlene's husband who doesn't want to
help anyone and just wants to scrooge
mcduck his neck broken Charlene's
husband wouldn't it be great if our
podcast was actually sponsored by
accounting like as an abstract idea if
like the American Association of
Accounting sent us a huge check every
week and we could just like find
different ways to work accounting into
the podcast or alternately if our
podcast was actually sponsored by
Wendy's or anyone wouldn't it be great
if someone paid us a
bunch of money to talk about their
product and/or service on our podcast I
was recently on Twitter trying to get
Lacroix to Center Lacroix sorry to send
me send me 378 12 packs of Lacroix which
is uh you know would make my life better
I'd talk about Lacroix all day on this
podcast if they'd send this god I some I
love Lacroix like if there's one thing
one way that my life has changed
demonstrably since the success of The
Fault in Our Stars it's that I now buy
as much Lacroix as I want which is a lot
you know John there's a thing about the
world that I kind of dislike right now
and that is the the sparkling Dasani and
Aquafina that I'm starting to see at
grocery stores because Lacroix found
this thing and they were like oh my gosh
we found a niche it's it's calorie-free
beverages that are flavored well and
that are refreshing when cooled and uh
and and they found a niche that liked
that coca-cola and Pepsi missed how
weird and amazing is that opportunity
and Lacroix does not have good graphic
design their logo is very weird
they're the copy that they like they're
their packaging copy never makes any
sense and always makes me just like
crave to like hire a good copywriter for
them and I feel like their CEO writes it
or something because it it's very like
disconnected from reality and then but
like it works it worked so well and it
becomes so popular and it frustrates me
to no end to know that somebody
coca-cola tried to buy Lacroix and
Lacroix was like no we're gonna do this
on our own and so they just came out
with these like beautiful sparkling
Dasani beverages and sparkling aquafina
beverages and are trying to take on the
croix and I'm like no no you will not
you cannot have this there's one thing
that you can't have and it's Lacroix
yeah I think I totally agree with you
but on the other hand if delicious
sparkling Dasani water wants me to drink
378 of their beverages and receive a
huge amount of money in exchange for
talking about how much I love sparkling
Dasani water I'm more than happy to do
that
yeah I totally agree with you I
it's so funny act like I the difference
is that I am serious I want to sell out
so bad and you don't you genuinely don't
want to sell out it's so annoying you
guys don't know about this because like
you not to deal with Hank in private but
like Hank will never sell out even in
tiny little delightful ways it's super
annoying that's not necessarily true
I sell out some ways no you don't you
really don't I struggle I struggle and I
go one way some days in another way
other days just not with our sort of
core properties of of like the the
brother stuff because I feel like who
needs it it's this is the thing we're
just messing around and that's like
that's why that's why we have spit fake
sponsorships even though I kind of feel
bad because of course many podcasts need
real sponsorships because they need to
make it work because they put in a great
deal of effort and they want to be
compensated for the great work that they
do but but we don't have to do that but
I mean but it's clear that Hank Hank
none of our listeners just just in case
you're concerned about this
none of our listeners labor under the
delusion that that we put in effort in
this podcast so you don't have to worry
about that no one's out there thinking
god they're working hard and not getting
paid for it they're out there thinking I
wonder when they're going to answer the
next question and the answer to that
question is now Hank this question comes
from Allison who writes dear John and
Hank hello my name is Allison Allison I
really like it when people repeat their
name so thank you my ice maker broke so
I Allison and currently using an ice
tray my question is when is the best
time to refill this ice tray dua Allison
wait until all the ice is gone or until
there are two to four cubes left I would
love to hear your opinions Hank I think
that this is one of those there's two
kinds of people in the world questions I
think there's one kind of people in the
world maybe two kinds of people in the
world one who hasn't heard about the
right way to do it and then there's the
other kind who just does it the right
way okay well why don't you just tell me
what the right way is as as well as you
usually do okay well in that case I
absolutely will thank you John you put
on a separate container in the freezer
and you empty out the ice tray into the
bucket
and then you refill the ice tray long
before you have used all of the ice
cubes you don't take individual cubes
out of the the thing you break the thing
and then you take all of them out at
once
I mean I and then I will tell you
something which is that that is a
brilliant solution that I have never
thought of in all of my many years of
not having an automatic icemaker uh let
me tell you the way I do it and then you
can tell me whether you think your way
or my way is better the way I do it and
I've done this we don't have an ice
maker now I haven't had an ice maker in
my fridge most of most of my adult life
and the way that I do it is that I have
a couple ice trays that have ice cubes
in them I take those trays I use all of
the ice cubes
I put empty trays back in the freezer
and then I go in to get ice cubes and
I'm like why did I not take three
seconds to fill up this with water six
hours ago
you idiot and then I get mad at myself I
drink a very warm lacroix while I'm
waiting for my new ice cubes to become
ice cubes and then I'm finally able to
enjoy delicious refreshing sparkling
grape fruit Lacroix available now at
grocery stores everywhere you know John
they recently I don't know how recently
but they have coconut Lacroix now and I
stayed stayed well away from it for a
while thinking and I'm not a big fan of
coconut I like Thai food though and I
like I like cracklin oat bran which has
a lot of coconut in it but for the most
part I'd prefer that not have to not
interact with coconut too much and I
drank it and I did not like it
somebody got it for a party I went to
was the only thing available I had
someone I was like yeah but then I mixed
it with with orange juice and I liked
that quite a lot and then I put some
lime juice in the coconut Lacroix and
that was very good and it's I thought to
myself my goodness I just put the lime
in the coconut and mix them both
together and drink it all up and I
thought that was a wonderful moment in
my life
it earns the laugh it's so terrible it's
like this
oh god it's extremely painful to laugh
okay I'm glad that you got that lime in
the coconut joke in there it only took
you four minutes to arrive at it was it
was one of those jokes where the moment
you said coconut lacroix I started to be
like is he going to put the lime in the
coconut and drink it all together and
the answer of course was yes Hank before
before we sell out any further to a
company that has given us no money or
any delicious beverages employed let's
get to the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon all right do you want to give
us some AFC Wimbledon news or I should I
tell you about the fascinating news from
Mars tell me the moves from Knorr okay
here's my here's my NARS mousse so nASA
has a program it's called the NASA
innovative advanced concepts program and
it helps sort of give small amounts of
funding to ideas that would be
revolutionary and would totally change
spaceflight but probably aren't gonna
turn in anything particularly useful and
one of the things that have gotten money
from Nayak recently is a research
project to induce a hibernation like
state at a state of torpor in astronauts
allowing them to basically sleep all the
way to Mars and the way that they would
do this is is using I know it's like we
talked about this in science fiction all
the time but they're actually like they
are looking to take a existing medical
technique called therapeutic hypothermia
and and actually apply that to healthy
people who just are taking up too much
space and eating too much food making it
impractical to get them to Mars and the
the application this would not be for
the first missions to Mars it would be
if we wanted to send like hundreds of
people to Mars and to basically actually
create a sustainable another human world
in our solar system and it would
dramatically reduce cut by a factor of
40 the amount of space that the
people would need on their trip to Mars
basically the technique works like this
they take your body temperature down
like five degrees and then they give you
some drugs that basically put you into a
kind of like suspended animation state
and that is a thing that they currently
do for people who have been badly
injured while they're working on
repairing their bodies it is a thing
that exists it is not particularly safe
and we don't of course they've never
tested it in microgravity but but it is
a thing that people are interested in
doing and would potentially be safer for
astronauts because they could put more
shielding on the containers they could
also their their muscles might generate
less in the time that they're traveling
to Mars than it would in a normal
microgravity environment while have like
being awake they would eat less food and
they would it would be easier to get
them there but it is definitely a thing
that is for the future but I was
fascinated to know oh sorry they
decreased the body temperature by nine
degrees Fahrenheit five degrees Celsius
and yeah it would it would make it a lot
easier to get a bunch of people to Mars
though to be clear it is just it is one
of those things that is a high payoff if
it works but probably won't work kind of
thing
follow-up question and I don't mean to
be insensitive in any way but do they
have the technology to blow your body
temperature by nine degrees Fahrenheit
and let you sleep off say a broken rib
injury yeah maybe I think usually and
you said it was you said it was risky so
I assume that it's not something I
probably want to do myself but yeah I
would love it if they could develop that
for the next time I break a rib because
this oh you know John I don't want to be
insensitive to your pain but I need you
I need you not in a hypothermia induced
torpor to do all that you like I feel
like things would be moving swimmingly
if I were in a hypothermia induced
torpor right now
speaking of hypothermia induced or its
will then continue their Ligue 1 season
as a third tier English football team
Hank you may remember that I said last
at the toward the end of last season if
by some miracle AFC Wimbledon were
promoted it would likely be a sort of a
one-year venture up there in the you
know the third tier of English football
so far that's looking it's a smidge
prophetic AFC Wimbledon very nearly won
their first game of the league one
season against Rockdale possibly
Rockdale nobody knows for sure how to
pronounce it they were up 1 nil in the
95th minute which is five minutes longer
than the game should have technically
gone on it was an injury time when
Rockdale scored to tie the game meaning
that AFC Wimbledon are now on two points
to the the bad news about that is that
Rockdale are also on two points they are
down there just above us at the very
very bottom of the table we are last
they are second-to-last so that is a
game that we would have needed to likely
probably would have been nice to win
that one but we didn't so here we are on
two points having played five games
that's not where you want to be but I
don't really have a but that is not I'm
sorry who's who who's been scoring for
you John well it in in it in summary no
one which is a bit of the issue you you
you have isolated there's sort of two
issues which is that we are not scoring
enough goals and then there's the second
issue which is that we are giving up too
many I feel like if we addressed either
of those issues it might it might lead
to a significant improvement in the
results
listen I'm not a football commentator
but I feel like if we were getting more
goals in and letting fewer in that we
would you know be be scoring more there
is some good news George Frankham the
Frankenstein is coming back after almost
like five months away
while Taylor has scored a couple of
goals there's a new there's a new guy
who's doing okay poley on he's been
scoring some goals dom poli on but no it
is not it's not great at the moment but
there's still a lot of season left it's
only five games in we'll see it just
googled AFC wimbledon and tuesday august
thirtieth wimbledon won against Swansea
City 3-0 ya know that's the Swansea City
under twenty three side not the grown up
Swansea City and it's in a it's in a
competition called the it's not the
league one competition and indeed or is
it the FA Cup it's this sort of it's the
Football League Cup which I believe
right now is called like the change away
cup or something because it has a
sponsor that's some betting site I don't
write it it's great to get a win in I'm
not sure that that really counts as a as
a proper victory though I would agree
with you I agree and I see now looking
at the league one table that indeed you
are 24th of 24 yes that is correct
sitting comfortably in 24th but I will
remind you if we finish 20 nope if we
finish 20th I don't think that I if we
fit we do all we have to do is finish
20th well or above you know that's not
nothing and then you can you can stick
it in there and maybe maybe you can get
against the Dons and you can if you
really only got to win one game this
season John and it's against the MK Dons
I prefer to think of them as the
franchise currently playing in Milton
Keynes since they have no right to use
the nickname of the Dons but yes I'd
like to win a bunch of games this season
but there are certainly two that I have
circled on the calendar all right well
John what did we learn today well we
learned that accounting is important
even if it's boring we learned that you
probably don't want to dive headfirst
into a vat full of coins so instead you
should fold them up into origami dollar
things and of course we also learned
that Hank has a significantly better way
of dealing with ice trays than John does
and finally we learned
that the Mars rover does not in fact
sing itself happy birthday every year
after a year it's been another year it's
been on Mars which is really too bad you
think they just like have it have a go
with that what's what harm isn't doing
come on let it sing itself a song alone
on a dark desolate planet until that
wonderful moment when a human comes up
and says how you doing buddy good work
and that's gonna happen in 2027 I can't
wait for that to happen in 2029 our
podcast is edited by nicholas jenkins
our intern is claudia morales rosianna
halse rojas helps us out with the
questions our theme music is by gonna
roll a hank i think i told people where
to email us but just in case if you want
to email us you can do so at Hank and
John at gmail.com I believe that covers
it except to say Hank yes as we say in
our hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]